Jenna those eyes you are the queen of I
acting young lady I wouldn't say that oh
but you are those eyes tell so much how
do you do like your eyes right now
you're kind of showing me up no no you
are so intense how do you do it what's
the trick when I shoot I black out I
have no idea what's going on I'm not
sure if I took the director's notes or
not you say action I don't remember
anything I feel like cut I kind of come
to you again the job is just listening
so I think you know depending on you
know just watching other people and you
know sometimes they do it differently
sometimes you react differently
sometimes you feel a certain way that
wasn't the same that you felt 20 minutes
ago I feel like um it's all just very
spontaneous see what happens well can we
be a little spontaneous right now can I
give you some emotions and you
demonstrate your different emotions with
your eyes okay I'm gonna do it and I'm
very excited about watching you do it
okay how about this anger
fear
this is so weird
should I go like this
happiness
I love it I love it it's so good so that
those eyes tell a story they are okay I
was so happy yeah
this isn't like any other ghost face
what is this place it's a shrine screen
six I mean there's so many references to
past sequels which was so exciting and
so satisfying for fans how exciting and
satisfying was it for you as actors to
pay homage to these sequels and also to
film and ghostface's Shrine oh it's
really cool I mean all the Easter eggs
are us as actors we get excited when we
see them on set yeah because it's all
mostly things that the directors have
thought of or like the production
designer has thought of and like we get
to set him we are also like the fans
that are noticing them and getting
excited because if it makes it on camera
then that means that the hardcore fans
are gonna be looking at all these things
it's like nostalgic and it makes you I
don't know I feel like whenever I notice
a little detail in a movie I get excited
because I feel like I'm a part of it
like you know like they're talking
directly to me and we are you know like
these movies are very interactive with
the audience so it's part of the game so
so good I'm ready for I'm ready for
number seven are y'all well we'll
hopefully yeah we'll see we'll see how
this one goes yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
still alive as a jam now I got to say
yeah she was cool for that that came out
of nowhere yeah no yeah and then the
directors told us yeah even to be able
to do press and stuff with her was
really interesting
right yeah hello Jenna get a job stay
away from her screaming Demi Lovato yeah
yeah it makes a lot of sense yeah it
somehow feels like the fact that there's
an original song for the movie feels big
and still alive y'all are still alive
so we think yeah without a doubt so the
torch was passed to you all the newbies
in Scream five of course Scream Six you
are full-fledged carrying that torch and
y'all are running with it so did it add
an extra element of pressure this time
around you were now the faces of this
franchise I feel like there was almost
more Liberty because we had already
established the characters in The Last
film and I I think it was just more time
to kind of elaborate and read more
dimensional characters and then also
it's um you've seen this world before
and I felt like this was the chance to
just kind of take it bigger and better I
feel like we got a lot of the nerves out
of the way yes from yourself I had a lot
of pressure yeah yeah how simple is
there it's just a lot you know coming
into a franchise that has been around
for so long is so beloved and people
love certain characters and they feel a
certain ownership over it Ruby this is
making a move
which is you know very real and very
true because it's thanks to the fans
that we've you know that the franchise
has been alive for so long so I don't
know I do I did feel a lot of pressure
but then you know being on set with
everyone that kind of like dissipates
and you forget about it because we're
having so much fun of course the
survivors from Scream five back together
again did it feel a little bit maybe
like a summer camp type of situation on
steroids I guess you could say totally
it almost if work didn't get stressful
sometimes it would it almost feels like
not work yes you're just seeing your
friends and you guys get to make
something exciting together and give
people a good time and you're all doing
what you're passionate about and I feel
like because we know each other so well
and love and respect each other so much
we when we feed off of each other it's
it's really nice yeah and we and it is a
special group of people because when
you're shooting a movie it can be so
exhausting and that you like literally
just want to go to bed I know that
that's what happens to me sometimes when
we're together we like want to hang out
after we're done we want to have dinner
together we want to go out on the
weekends we want to just be with each
other and have fun and play Mafia like
you know we do it is a genuine love for
each other so it does feel like summer
camp yeah I mean it totally resonates on
screen that you guys are thick as
thieves and you're super tight I loved
loved loved this film and we got a
little behind the scenes fun action of
you guys while you're on set ET dead the
last scream that we did was probably the
greatest time I've ever had on a set
just truly the most wonderful sweetest
cast crew so I think that anytime you
get to work with people that you love
you're one you're very very lucky I feel
very very fortunate but then two it's um
I came into this job knowing it was just
going to be a good time and it was I'm
gonna feel like work Jenna you were in
the fridge you know we're doing some
funny like Instagram video another time
you were don't spoil the movie
okay
balancing tortillas on your head so you
try to keep it light and fun in between
takes because things can get a little
heavy while filming I imagine now I
actually do stuff like that to scare
myself and kind of keep myself on the
edge of you know it tells you know I
don't want to drop anything on the floor
I feel like in the fridge it's really
isolating as soon as the door is closed
and it's dark in there and it's cold and
distant yeah she she uses it to get into
characters seriously yeah seriously
getting in the fridge yeah are you guys
well because it's a moment of resetting
right before take so there's no
distractions you know anything is just
you with your thoughts and you get the
time to really amp yourself up girl
that's the method acting right there
almost tell me this though leave it in
the fridge yeah just Melissa you are
Jenna's big movie Sister you know how
excited have you been for her seeing the
success of Wednesday how the hell did
you get that oversized violin out the
window
I had an extra hand
of course the Globes the SAG Awards I
mean she deserves everything she is so
talented and it feels so right that like
she's getting all the recognition but
I'm also very protective of her and I
know that it's like it can get crazy so
it's you know I'm glad that we're all
here together and that she gets to have
this kind of Refuge in the middle of all
the craziness but she's killing it and
I'm so excited to see her on SNL OMG how
pumped are you about that I'm trying to
take it one day at a time right now but
it's nice doing it yeah with everyone
else as you know I I am nervous but
excited at the same time just because
I've been a fan of the show for such a
long time but it's also I've never
really done sketch comedy like that
before and um I think it'll be really
quick Pace but I'm excited to be in
front of an audience I feel like you
yeah learn so much when you do theater
and stuff like that so that'll be a nice
change of pace without a doubt might we
see Aubry Plaza pop back up into the
middle I have no idea I feel like she
could pop up anywhere she could be
behind that door she used to work in
that building I think she still has
access yeah
foreign
[Music]
okay